bonjour Olivier Devaux président de la
Société azzare réunion accueille sûreté
assistance spécialisé donc dans les
métiers de la sûreté aéroportuaire
entreprise qui a été créée en 2004 que
nous avons racheté en 2008 qui
dénombrait à l'époque pas loin de 70 à
80 salariés actuellement en 2014 nous
pouvons dénombrer donc plus de 140
agents avec toute la structure qui est
qui va avec faut savoir que cette
entreprise là a été spécialisée donc
dans la sûreté aéroportuaire s'est
développée dans la sûreté portuaire qui
est actuellement une activité assez
novatrice et nous avons pu développer
donc la première branche que je
maîtrisais moi à l'époque en 2002 à
savoir le gardiennage prestation de
surveillance et gardiennage de bien et
de personnes
est donc à la recherche de d'agents de
sécurité dans le domaine donc je stipule
bien de sécurité non pas sûreté puisque
nous sommes en plein développement sur
cette phase sécurité gardiennage nous
aurions donc besoin de compléter notre
équipe de d'agents confirmés mais
également de jeunes qui sera en
possession de dehors CQP de leur diplôme
leur CAP d'agent de prévention et
sécurité mais aussi des plus anciens
donc les seniors qui seraient également
donc capable d'assumer ces postes à
également responsabilités puisque nous
avons besoin encore une fois de
développer ces domaines qui sont qui
s'offrent à nous actuellement et qui
demandent donc une équipe sérieuse et
soudée alors si vous souhaitez intégrer
une entreprise sérieuse et dynamique
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter et à
déposer un CV nous vous recontacterons
en vue d'un entretien
bonjour je suis Jean-Pierre adras je
travaille dans le bâtiment depuis 30 ans
j'adore ce métier j'étais chef
d'entreprise à deux reprises j'ai 30 ans
d'expérience et modèle bâtiment j'ai
travaillé comme pour des entreprises GTI
PCPC je précise en qualité de
sous-traitant et pas mal aussi mes
qualités
je dirais mon boulot et moi je l'adore
j'ai toujours rêvé été modal bâtiment
j'ai toujours aimé à faire ce que je
fais je suis quelqu'un de très sérieux
je ne plaisante pas et j'aime bien que
les choses soient faites et moi dans
l'ensemble
avec moi on joue pas je suis rigoureux
et j'aime le travail en équipe je suis
disponible n'hésitez pas de m'appeler
bonjour je m'appelle Jean Jo j'ai 50 ans
j'habite Saint-Denis je suis véhiculé je
cherche un emploi de chauffeur-livreur
poseur de store ou menteur de meubles je
peux me déplacer sur toute l'île j'ai le
cap mécanique et le justificatif de
capacité professionnelle trois tonnes 5
j'ai 4 ans d'expérience dans une
entreprise de transport où j'effectuais
la livraison et la pose de store et nous
faisions aussi du montage de meubles je
suis travailleur rigoureux et j'aime
comme mon travail ça fait sérieusement
je suis motivé si vous êtes intéressé
par mon profil contactez-moi
bonjour je m'appelle Jean Casanove je le
permis B et j'habite à Saint-Denis j'ai
46 ans
je cherche un prof comme ferrailleur
dans le Nord SOS
j'aime EP grosses maçonnerie j'ai fait
un stage en maçonnerie ferrailleur
pourquoi moins cher à la fin j'ai
travaillé à la GTI bwe et une entreprise
de droite en tant que ferrailleur et
j'ai 18 ans d'expérience il fut rappelé
j'aime la communication et travailler en
équipe
bon mes loisirs sont le vélo la marche à
pied et un peu de course à pied
on va chez moi
facebook.com/974tv ou par téléphone 0262
92 37 60
9 7 4 CV votre émission au service de
l'emploi à la Réunion